hello there citizens of the reject me hello
there Citizens We're gonna watch uh episode
four of tales of the Jedi I believe this is the
longest one they have 45 minutes this one is two
hours two hours could have been a full-length
feature film but here we are joined by Michael
B Michael business is the kids on the streets
of Harlem call them Omni media check out his
channel awesome reaction Channel Michael how
are you you've been enjoying tales as a Jedi
I have it's been really intriguing so far we had
one Ahsoka two dookus and I'm ready for more of
the same I don't know we'll find out next time
on Dragon Ball Z it's been a little bit more uh
serialized than I expected especially with the
Dooku storyline I was like oh yeah it's not like
you know take days later but there's a there's
definitely a specific story they're actually
telling I thought it would just be like pure
anthology that's what I kind of thought too but
uh it definitely built off of the one we watched
before yeah um and I'm I'm wondering I'm I'm just
kind of curious we had two dookus back to back I
wonder what the next one's gonna be very curious
yeah yeah it'll be a Sarge Ventress um all right
guys well uh leave a like subscribe and also uh
you could support us on patreon we get the
rash and watch alongs there let's get to it
good
it's like poetry Rhymes they
should add that to the intro
every time it says lucasfilm it's
like poetry right it's just a insane
poetry rhymes
again core side you greedy sons of
[__] only looking out for yourselves
dude with a longer longer beard
this is just the story of Dooku's beard
yeah it's the it's a Serpico story
yeah how much time has passed
please enter security clearance code
is the same button three times deleting
oh my God now archive data deleted wow plans in
effect it's his fault a bunch of children are
gonna cost Obi-Wan later Michael yes it would seem
he has encountered a Sith Lord or so he claimed
to the Jedi where was this encounter tattooing
I was taking place during episode one Seattle
yeah oh nice I encountered a highly skilled
Warrior one obviously trained in the jedale yards
this Lord is not to be trifled with and I will
not be there to protect you Obi-Wan fills that
role now he acquits himself quite well that's
good I should like to meet him someday oh you
will many times many times too they grow up
so fast our students I must take my leave
she can sense the darkness within him
I mean he must be just meeting yeah
like she also just mysteriously disappears
between movies at one point the Sith Lord
uh I used to bring quite long here as a boy
fascinated with this tree having
been born here on coruscants
so there's leaving for Naboo the
funeral is to be held there oh got it
Qui-Gon Jinn has become one with the force
it is time to let him go and you can do this
what choice have I oh that is interesting feels
like one of his final dark pushes was the death of
Qui-Gon that's fascinating it makes me think back
to because like you know when he captures Obi-Wan
he tries to recruit him I do really like
the music a lot it's real Sci-Fi tune to it
followed
is this why she disappears
dude
beautiful this is yeah man
Coruscant on the the Twilight this is the
first episode I have like and or Vibes yeah
this is where we saw him meet
Sidious at the end of uh attack
oh no
it's really difficult to stealthily follow someone
with a ship you know yeah you've gone too far
doing don't know what you mean
you know exactly what it means
you allowed Maul to kill him you
lost an apprentice and so did I
all in service of our greater goals the
Galaxy would not be remarried without
sacrifice wow man you question my loyalty
always you have been loyal to a greater cause
how many have died because of my
actions such is the price of freedom
no no no no this is so foreboding
so I have been betrayed no
I will kick her away oh he's gonna have
don't believe her
whatever lies he's told you
whatever you have done you can make up for
it now by bringing him to Justice oh this
is so sad the Jedi blindly serve a corrupt
Senate that failed the Republic it represents
you want to prove your loyalty
killer goddamn Palpatine uh the devil and
the angel man I'm afraid it is too late
yes damn this is crazy how
tragic this is for uh Dooku
after a point he can't go back are you he
doesn't believe he can go back
quiet gone did not have to die
so you kind of Hope Dooku oh dude
this music man yeah it's beautiful
oh my God oh what a way to go out God
damn you have done well my Apprentice
screw you Palpatine rise my friend master
oh oh [__] boss move
no he's looking at the light
this is so heartbreaking I don't think
I've ever felt so bad for Dooku or yaddle
so many have suffered for what
you call order let me give you
jeez wow
well I got like chills everywhere
oh my spot doesn't like that man
this is really this is really well done you know
before we started uh Michael and I were talking
about how we heard some opinions out there
people were just being like yeah it's fine
it's there's kind of like the writer right
through here I'm like no it's fine that's
what we heard some opinions like oh Eric I only
heard like a couple yeah they're people really
associated with the Star Wars Community but I
think these are dunce like we're more than we're
we're two-thirds of the way through it and
I'm like this is really well done like this
is this is incredibly done I think uh this is
brilliant man yeah this is amazing this is It's
So effective and and um it's such a great mood
to it and like I did not expect walking in here
I thought at most I'd be like okay yeah it's
kind of interesting to see what happened with
Dooku but to really feel for the downfall here
yeah um like there's such pathos to it all and
with the adult too like obviously that fight's
gonna be compared to you know Yoda and him an
attack of the Clones and while that fight is
a lot more exciting because it's like you're
out of fighting and it's it's so cathartic
and he's like flipping around like a madman
that's what I think it's like he's gone crazy he's
flipping all over the place uh there this this
fight had so much emotion to it though so in a lot
of ways I prefer it because because of the fact
that there's such there's such emotional weight
and there's a fight for a man's Soul right now
and you just know the inevitable that's not gonna
pan out with how she intends and there's frames so
just so perfectly the whole time too like she
could sense what's going on in his head like
because every time he's what in a moment of
vulnerability we see yaddle there like exactly
trying to like kind of I don't know like keep
an eye over him not like watch him or be like
you know not from like a point of like uh fear
or anything like that or whatever it was always
concern and compassion for her like it's not
the way Mace Windu would watch her watch him he
would be like am I gonna have to cut it I have to
cut his head right now and she's just like she's
there at every step of the way with open arms
yeah like willing probably more than willing
to have heard him out if he ever expressed his
concerns but he he's so distanced at this point
and from what we see he's already gone down the
path to start actually it's no more it's no longer
just feelings he's committed to actions by this
point yeah he's done things despite the kind of
conflict despite the fact that he he hasn't
in his heart he still questions things but
even like and you know what this really did
as much time as we've spent with Palpatine
in so many so like he's been around forever
you know so it's been so much time with this
Palpatine guy and I'll be honest this was
like the first time I found myself actually
mad at him in a scene if that makes sense I was
like I can kind of agree I was like just like a
short way because like we just like and maybe
that's part of why like the time we've spent
with Dooku up to this point yeah partially where
I was like I am so you're you're pissing me off
so much dude I was like there's like a couple
times like you know equipped for the reaction
and stuff every now and then but whatever there
was like a moment there where I I like physically
stopped myself from being like shut the [__] up
yeah no he got yeah it was it was actually uh guys
as much like manipulating and whatever that we've
seen Palpatine do in this particular the immediacy
of the emotions of this this moment in time I was
like wow I'm actually like really mad at Palpatine
or anything and I've never felt that I've never
been uh like upset at what he's doing so I thought
that was effective It's very effective it's
like this was a really Sinister episode and
I like the I like the uh how they're actually
all connected and you do see like we don't need
to see how him and like it'd be cool to see how
we met Palpatine how he like got acquainted with
him and stuff and yeah how this journey began you
know yeah I would like to kind of I'm curious how
Palpatine reached out I don't remember if that
got touched on via phone call you're like hey
man uh I saw you know got your email I saw you
on LinkedIn yeah some interesting things to say
the uh well I think what they're doing more than
focusing on on like like while there's plot points
obviously they're focusing on the emotional
turning points for you the most that's that's
what it's that's what the plot points are going
to serve is the emotion and I think like even with
the music choices that they have and the way they
choose to capture each specific episode it's it's
imbued in the emotion so much and and I feel like
that's what makes it so easy to connect to and so
quickly that like I'll be on like Dooku's always
been like a cool character to me but I've never
yeah I've never really been one to be like what's
his origin like I want to see what happens yeah I
uh just in preparation for this honestly is where
I've gotten really intrigued by his character in
a way that I have not been um because like
he's cool in the Clone Wars and they do
you do I get the sense that when he's introduced
an attack of the Clones that there was a point
where I could feel like there was a point where
he probably believed in his Crusade um but like
but you didn't really dive into it at all and you
just kind of forget about it like once he starts
fighting Yoda and Anakin Obi and all that stuff
like it's just like a momentary okay well as much
as like characters have downfalls with the tragic
downfalls where they turn to the dark side this
is that rare instance where I'm like I really get
why he turned to the dark side like it really it
really makes sense to me because there's a version
of this where you're like I can't really come from
us might be a hot thing I don't know it
makes way more sense than Anakin turned
turning definitely no I I will I will back you
I will back you 100 um but like it's almost a
very similar beat sure you know when he Palpatine
also there being his little shit-eating grin self
when Anakin cut off mace's hand and he was
like oh well I guess there's no going back
it was like we kind of had a little bit of a
moment there with the with the Great when the
grape actually fell on yaddle I think like at the
moment when he realized like oh wait did this just
happen even though it didn't yet I think at that
point he was like okay well I guess I gotta commit
now yeah but it was it was honestly it was more
effectively done than that same scene in Revenge
of the Sith as much as I love that movie man but
it's not for the the art that's my favorite of the
three obviously um for many people too but yeah I
think this I think this has done so well that with
with people who have just been like it's fine it's
not necessary I'm like I don't know man this is
like great dude like this is really dude could you
imagine if the prequels was like this yeah this
was the story this is this is great stuff I I'm
really really on on a very like the first episode
with the Soca which I do find to be an interesting
choice because Ahsoka is obviously can't I mean I
don't really know how Ahsoka ages but that has
got to be after a lot of this because Anakin is
not even in the picture yet right well he is as
like as Jake Lloyd but yeah um in this episode
uh but you know so I'm like that's a that's
an interesting choice and I like that episode
um but yeah obviously the real
like whoa this is truly gripping
um as a term with the Dooku side so yeah I
mean we gotta move on to five and six but
I don't know I have an idea of where this might
be going but we'll talk about it when we get to it
yeah because I I feel like there is I think these
are well Justified I think it's existence is well
Justified I'm honestly a little disappointed
that there's only two more of these left
yeah they could have made a real series out of the
Dooku storyline it's been so compelling it's been
very compelling um but I also like the chunks and
uh and the time jumps and stuff uh they actually
and it helps you like if you're a little
acquainted but yeah this this has so much more
layers to Dooku um make it make for an interesting
experience when going back through clone wars and
whenever you see Dooku you know because he
anyway uh yeah let's move on episode five
oh yeah but guys uh what'd you think leave a like
subscribe click that Bell follow Michael on his
uh YouTube page and uh we'll talk soon talk
soon talk to you say hi to your mother for me